you know that i am
really really obsessed with the kanye
west kim kardashian skeet davidson saga
i am i don't care i don't really follow
pop culture at all this story i'm really
really taken with
because i think it actually cuts down to
some of the core political issues in
america and also because kanye west is
very very funny and also because skeet
davidson is just not very likable
there's a headline
comes out of people magazine skeet
davidson is in trauma therapy
because of the taunts from kanye west
the attention and negativity coming from
kanye and his antics is a trigger for
davidson and he's had to seek out help
davidson has been in therapy
trauma therapy since april in large part
due to his beef with kanye west
i'm not surprised that pete davidson is
in therapy
pete davidson probably should be in
therapy he's had kind of a difficult
life his his dad famously died in 911
sort of heroically i think he was a new
york firefighter he goes in on 911 as a
hero of that day and so this is when
skeet davidson's a kid obviously that's
a trauma and he's engaged in all sorts
of destructive behaviors and now what
because kanye west makes fun of him on
instagram that's it that's what sends
him over the edge no i'm sure the guy's
got a lot of of issues but kanye west
was absolutely right
is absolutely right to taunt skeet
davidson skeet davidson played a large
role in breaking up kanye west's
marriage and that's a no-no folks that's
a no-no you don't get to do that
marriage is sacred and the fundamental
building block of society and some
dirty looking snl actor does not have
the right to come in and take your wife
from you and then he also taunted kanye
west he would send him pictures
apparently while lying in bed with with
kim kardashian and say oh i'm in bed
with your wife hahaha
no you don't get to do that
this this story the reason i'm obsessed
with it is it's about a lot more than
kanye west and skeet davidson and kim
kardashian and yes i'm aware all of
these people have lived extremely
colorful eccentric in in many ways not
particularly virtuous lives but that's
even more to the point because while
they are
really wild crazy examples of hollywood
extreme and decadence in many ways
they're very human in many ways they're
representative of a lot of americans who
have kind of messy lives who have had
messy love lives and and
and
unclear and conflicting understandings
of how we ought to behave and they're
seeing that play out and all i know is
through these imperfect vessels you saw
kanye west at least
trying to save his marriage at least
saying that he wanted to save his
marriage he was the representative of
that and this was after he had some kind
of conversion or reversion to
christianity and was very public about
that this is after he espoused some
broadly conservative political views and
social views
then you had kim kardashian go into a
magazine and say in my 40s i'm just
going to live for me and i'm just going
to do whatever i want it's about me me
me which she's the voice of a generation
that's why she's so popular and then you
had skeet davidson come in here and go
and steal another man's wife
so shameful so dishonorable
and you think among these three people
who am i going to pick i'm going to say
kanye now some people will then come out
on this story and they'll say kanye has
no right
no right whatsoever
to
try to save his marriage or try to
attack the person who's helping to break
up his marriage what are you talking
about the people who say that are the
ones who think marriage doesn't mean
anything that marriage can be easily
dissolved at any given time that it's
just it's just a kind of contract you
can break the contract well it's a
contract except
nothing about it is binding so it's not
even a contract it's just two people
kind of get along together for a little
and then whenever you don't like each
other as much anymore you know he didn't
do the dishes last night and she's
getting a little older and so we're just
gonna split it up and move on no no that
might be the live view of marriage
that is not the conservative view of
marriage
and the libview says we're all
individuals and can do whatever the hell
we want whenever we want to do it the
conservatives say no the fundamental
political unit is the marriage and when
you make that vow
you're in it buddy you're stuck with it
this was the mainstream view in america
for a very very long time
now that's considered extreme people are
actually saying they're saying kanye's
gone too far here it is here's a
headline from metro kanye has gone too
far
neither his genius or his mental health
are excuses why because he's defending
his marriage
kanye west
kanye west some years ago put on a big
giant foam suit and danced around to a
song singing you're such an effing hoe i
love it do you remember that
you're such a [ __ ] hoe
when the first time they asked you you
want sparkling or steal are you trying
to act like you drinking sparkling water
before you came out here
you're such a i'm a sick i like a quick
i'm a sick i like a quick
i'm a sick i like a quick
i'm a sick i like a quick
i'm a sick i like a quick i like my i
buy
[Music]
how you start a family the condom
slipped up i'm a sick [ __ ] i'm
inappropriate i like hearing stories i
like that host i wanna hear more i like
the whole [ __ ] send me some motions you
triflin
we had to blur out half of that song i
kind of forgot when i sent the clip that
we'd have to bleep out actually half of
the song that wasn't too far you're such
an effing hoe i love it i like to get my
well i can't even say it i'd have to
bleep out myself that's not too far
remember when kanye west went on t
national tv and he said that george bush
doesn't like black people
a lot of the people that could help are
at war right now fighting another way
and they they've given them permission
to go down and shoot us
and subtle but in even many ways more
profoundly devastating is the lasting
damage to the survivor's will to rebuild
and remain in the area the destruction
of the spirit of the people of southern
louisiana and mississippi may end up
being the most tragic loss of all george
bush doesn't care about black people
please call
in the past few days
you remember that that that wasn't too
far that was genius that was all an
example of kanye's eccentric genius but
then kanye comes out and he says hey i
don't want to get divorced i think
marriage is a real thing and we should
stay together for the purpose of our for
the sake of our children and because we
took a vow and we should take this
marriage seriously and skeet davidson
should get the hell out of my bed
that's too far that's crazy
that hold you're defending marriage you
don't think that this sort of filthy
looking new yorker young guy should be
crawling around in your bed around your
house where your children sleep you
don't think that wow totally crazy there
was an article
in
i think it was the week or somewhere i
don't know occasionally i get google
alerts and they were going after me
because i said that we should defend
marriage and they said you know
republicans republicans are coming for
no fault divorce next to which i say
i hope so
yeah you damn right we should i don't
know that we will because so many
republicans are so squishy and useless
but we certainly should go for no fault
divorce no fault divorce is insane
and it's a complete aberration in
american history new york did not have
no fault divorce on the books new york
one of the most liberal states in the
country did not have no fault divorce on
the books
until 2010. no fault divorce is a very
very modern invention
it really only began to be popularized
in the 1960s and 70s before that
you had something known as wedlock you
had something known as marriage you went
out you took a vow before god
most importantly and before your spouse
and before the political community
and you said i'm going to stay in this
marriage
for ever till death do us part and if
you wanted a divorce divorce has existed
throughout all of human history but it
was hard it was discouraged all of the
political and social and legal incentive
was to remain married and work it out
and fix your marriage
and then in the 70s up really up until
just some a few years ago
there was this movement to say nah never
mind whatever we should all just get
divorced and be single and live for
ourselves and do whatever we want the
minute the going gets tough we should
just cut and run and you know it's going
to screw over our kids and it's going to
traumatize a lot of people and it's
going to cause complete disorder in our
country because if you if effectively
abolish the the fundamental political
institution
you necessarily are causing a massive
amount of disorder but whatever
love is love the heart wants what the
heart wants whatever it's due you can't
make me do anything
choice choice choice individual autonomy
above all else
of course at
a conservative at the
bare minimum
must oppose
no false divorce
no fault people blame gay marriage
people blame the hookup culture people
blame all sorts of things for our social
uh
disarray that we find ourselves in and
all those things have contributed to it
no fault divorce might be
the biggest cause it's certainly up
there i mean no fault it is a major
issue republicans are coming for no
fault of worse aha
yeah i hope so or the republicans aren't
worth their salt
i'm glad you like that clip now make
sure you ring the bell and subscribe
we've now got over a million subscribers
i'm very grateful for that that's cool
this has become one of the largest
youtube channels out there but i want it
to be the very largest i want it to be
number one that means i need a billion
subscribers okay and that's going to be
a little bit of a lift but we can do it
make sure send it to your friends bing
bang subscribe ding dong whatever you
got to do we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]